Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是马丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件目前正在发生的激动人心的事。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是把时间无休止地出卖给金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）主办的“通往持续收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康从业者，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都对你适用。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还将有机会赢得与我——马丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一一小时指导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你正准备成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。节目。特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）欢迎收看《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. We can be pretty good in the mental health industry at trying to polish up the dull side of a penny and finding advantages and certainly one of the advantages I found about the lockdowns was how much more immersed in nature I was able to be so it gave me time to slow everything down and I was going out for more walks and I even started running so being able to see you know and, you know, making way for summer, making way for autumn and then winter as well. And seeing the change in the seasons for me felt like a really nice opportunity. found new ways to welcome kind of nature and wildlife into their daily lives and into their well-being too and into their schedules too. I made contact with somebody who is a nature wildlife specialist because I thought it'd be really nice for us to learn a bit about the
我是马丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。在心理健康行业，我们非常擅长把事情好的一面挖掘出来，寻找积极的因素。封锁期间我发现的好处之一，绝对是我能够更加沉浸在大自然中。这让我有时间放慢一切，我出去散步的次数变多了，甚至开始跑步。能够看到，你知道的，迎来了夏天、秋天，还有冬天。看到季节的变幻，对我觉得是一个非常好的机会。人们找到了将自然和野生动物融入日常生活、融入福祉以及日程安排的新方法。我联系了一位自然野生动物专家，因为我觉得让我们了解一些
benefits of being out and about in the outdoors. But also thinking about the benefits we can highlight to our clients through something called green prescribing. We are all human. And my guest contacted me after we'd recorded this to say that he had accidentally got spring watch and autumn watch muddled up. So it isn't spring watch that's going to be um potentially discontinued it's autumn watch so when you get to that bit um if you're watching on youtube it will pop up on the screen to explain the mix-up but if you um get to that bit and you're listening on the podcast then yeah we mean the other way around um so it's not spring watch that's potentially stopping it is autumn watch so i hope that clears up any confusion i have also
置身户外的益处会非常棒。同时，我们也可以思考如何通过一种名为“绿色处方”（green prescribing）的方式，向我们的客户强调这些益处。人非圣贤，孰能无过。我的嘉宾在我录完这期节目后联系我，说他刚才不小心把“春日观察”（Springwatch）和“秋日观察”（Autumnwatch）给弄混了。所以潜在可能被停播的并不是“春日观察”，而是“秋日观察”。所以当你听到那部分时，如果你是在 YouTube 上观看，屏幕上会弹出说明来解释这个口误；但如果你听到那部分时是在听播客，那么，是的，我们说的是反过来的情况——所以潜在停播的不是“春日观察”，而是“秋日观察”。希望这能消除任何误解。我还
been notified that you can actually do reviews and ratings on spotify so i know most of you do listen on spotify that is our most popular streaming platform. So if you indeed are listening on Spotify, please do take a moment to rate and review the show. I don't use Spotify. I haven't got Spotify. So I don't know how to talk you through that process. But if you do use Spotify, do have a little look and let me know. Maybe send me some screenshots of how you do it so I can explain it to other people that would be so wonderful so I hope you find today's episode really useful um yeah it's a little bit different today but I think it's really useful to give you a breadth of things that are useful to you as an aspiring psychologist and a mental health professional so you find it useful,
接到通知，其实你可以在 Spotify 上进行评论和评分。我知道你们大多数人都是在 Spotify 上收听的，那是我们最受欢迎的流媒体平台。所以如果你确实是在 Spotify 上收听，请花一点时间给节目打分和评论。我不用 Spotify，我也没有 Spotify，所以我不知道该怎么指导你们完成这个过程。但如果你确实使用 Spotify，请看一看并告诉我。也许可以发给我一些操作截图，这样我就可以向其他人解释了，那真是太棒了！希望大家觉得今天的节目非常有用。嗯，今天的节目有点不同，但我认为它能为你提供广泛的实用内容，对作为有志心理学家和心理健康从业者的你非常有用。希望你觉得有收获，
I'll catch up with you on the other side. So welcome to my guest today, Dan Lovard. Hi. Hi, Marion. How are you? I'm really well, thank you. Thanks for asking. How are you? Yes, I'm good, thank you. So I'm on your mailing list for where you work, which is how I heard about you and your work. And I was intrigued to learn a little bit more and to help our audience learn a little bit more about wildlife and being out in nature and how that can be really beneficial for our mental health if we are working in mental health and also for our clients that we work with as well. Yeah, so I'm happy to talk more about what we offer at Warwickshire Wildlife Trust. So we have a health and wellbeing team and they deliver a variety of different opportunities for people to be inspired and engage in nature activities. So we run well-being courses, which are in line with the five ways to well-being, which you might be aware of. And they're the nationally recognised approaches, if you like, the NHS came up with.
我们稍后见。欢迎今天的嘉宾丹·洛瓦德（Dan Lovard）。你好。你好，马丽安。你好吗？我很好，谢谢。谢谢你的关心。你呢？是的，我很好，谢谢。我是你工作单位的邮件订阅用户，这就是我如何得知你和你的工作的。我很想了解更多，并帮助我们的观众更多地了解野生动物、亲近自然，以及如果我们从事心理健康工作，这如何对我们的心理健康大有裨益，同时也对我们合作的客户有所帮助。是的，我很乐意多谈谈我们在沃里克郡野生动物信托基金（Warwickshire Wildlife Trust）提供的内容。我们有一个健康与福祉团队，他们为人们提供各种不同的机会，以激发和参与自然活动。我们开设了福祉课程，这与“福祉五种方式”（five ways to well-being）相一致，你们可能听说过。这些是国家认可的方法，可以说是 NHS（国民保健署）提出的。
And we've put that in a nature context, which has worked really well. And we've received so much positive feedback and stories from them being a part of those courses. So, yeah, I can delve into with the five ways and those five ways are connect, take notice, give back, get active and learn something new. So putting that into a nature context, you know, going for a long walk and running some mindfulness activities, which have all been really impactful ways for people to connect with nature and with the people around them as well. And then other things that we run within the health and wellbeing team are bushcraft activities, so a bit more hands-on practical firelighting activities. So bring out, sort of like you're in a kid in a way, when you might go into the woods
我们将其置于自然背景中，效果非常好。我们收到了很多积极的反馈，以及人们参与这些课程的故事。所以，是的，我可以深入探讨这五种方式，这五种方式分别是：建立联系、保持觉察、回馈社会、保持活力和学习新知。将其融入自然背景中，比如进行长途漫步并开展一些正念活动，这些都是人们与自然以及周围人建立联系的极具影响力的有效方式。我们在健康与福祉团队开展的其他活动还包括森林求生技能（bushcraft）活动，也就是更具实操性的生火活动。这有点像唤醒你内心的童真，当你走进树林
and do a variety of different things. And then also we run volunteering activities, which we do as an organisation, we offer those across the board actually in our organisation. So we have 65 nature reserves and within those volunteers that we have, about 700, they're the lifeblood of our organisation for us to be managing those sites to support wildlife. So we run volunteering activities for people that experience poor ill health that may have been signposted by their GPs, along with other social prescribers as well. And then they can get out onto our nature reserves with one of our project officers and get stuck in and use nature in a sort of green prescribing way, if you like. Brilliant. And that's really powerful and i
做各种各样的事情时。此外，我们还开展志愿服务活动。作为一家机构，我们在整个组织范围内都提供这些机会。我们拥有 65 个自然保护区，在我们的志愿者中，大约有 700 人是维持我们组织管理这些保护区以支持野生动物的生命线。因此，我们为经历健康状况不佳、可能由全科医生（GP）以及其他社会处方师转介的人士组织志愿服务活动。然后，他们可以在我们的一位项目官员的带领下进入自然保护区，全身心投入，以某种绿色处方的方式亲近自然。太棒了！这真的很有力量，而且
think it's like you said it's the mindfulness aspect of it um but also and it's something people can feel a bit apprehensive about doing things that are new but it sounds like that doesn't need to be the case when you're when you're going to these wildlife centers because there will be people who are really thrilled to talk to you and guide you through what you might be looking at or what you might like to look for? Yes definitely so we do completely recognise that there are some barriers with people accessing nature whether that be a fear of safety and being out on their own in a woodland for example can be daunting for some people. And maybe they don't feel that nature's for them and it's not relevant to their lives.
正如你所说，这就像是正念的体现。但同时——人们在尝试新事物时可能会感到有些担忧——不过听起来，当你去这些野生动物中心时，情况并非如此，因为那里会有非常乐意与你交谈并指导你观察或寻找心仪事物的人。是的，绝对是这样的。所以我们完全意识到人们在接触自然时存在一些障碍，无论是对安全的担忧，例如独自一人在林地里可能会让有些人感到畏惧。也许他们觉得大自然不属于他们，与他们的生活无关。
But as an organisation, we're really keen to instil a level of nature into people's lives because we know how important and powerful it is to nurture people's mental health. So, yeah, we are as welcoming as we can be and we do go out into the community quite a lot through our outreach work to inspire and connect the more disengaged audiences in society within Warwickshire, Coventry and Solihull. Yeah and you know what I'm I've been to your um to your center with my specifically with my young children when they're a little bit younger and what i really like is you've got a cafe there
但作为一个组织，我们非常渴望在人们的生活中注入一定程度的自然元素，因为我们深知这对于培育人们的心理健康是多么重要和强大。所以，是的，我们尽可能地热情欢迎大家，我们通过外展工作深入社区，去启发和连接沃里克郡、考文垂和索利哈尔社会中那些较少参与自然的人群。是的，你知道吗，我曾经带着我年纪还小的时候的孩子去过你们的中心。我非常喜欢的一点是，你们那里还有一家咖啡馆
as well and there's a tv where at the time you could see like i think it was kestrels on the roof of a local building with their little their little chicks was it kestrels i'm not sure so So they're peregrines. Peregrine falcons. They're in the same family of birds of prey. But yeah, we have a webcam, which is in, it's a partnership project with Warwick District Council. And yeah, we have a successful pair of nesting peregrines in the town hall in Leamington. So we also have access to the webcam feed and yes we play that along with them some of the smaller bird box birds like blue tits and great tits and things and that we have on our
此外，那里还有一个电视屏幕，当时你可以看到，我记得是红隼（kestrels）在一个当地建筑的屋顶上，带着它们的小雏鸟。那是红隼吗？我不太确定。所以那是游隼（peregrines）。游隼。它们属于猛禽的同一个科。不过，是的，我们有一个网络摄像头，这是一个与沃里克区议会（Warwick District Council）合作的项目。是的，我们在利明顿（Leamington）市政厅有一对成功筑巢的游隼。所以我们也可以通过网络摄像头观看实时画面，是的，我们会播放这个画面，还有我们在保护区里安放的一些较小的鸟巢里的鸟类，比如蓝山雀（blue tits）和大山雀（great tits）等。
reserves and that's such an intimate way to connect with nature isn't it seeing the whole breeding cycle of them raising their chicks to them fledging it's yeah really fantastic isn't it it really was and it was fascinating stuff and to sit there with my little boy and have our lunch and watch these baby chicks eating their lunch like it was really really nice so that yeah and I guess if and I think you also had bird tables set up outside the windows to the cafe as well so even if you're not feeling like confident or if you're not that good kind of mobility wise about getting out and about there's ways for you to engage with nature and see stuff that you might not see in your own house or from your own balcony
以如此亲密的方式与大自然建立联系，真是太棒了，不是吗？看着它们繁育后代的整个周期，从养育雏鸟到雏鸟离巢，这真的是太棒了，不是吗？确实非常棒，而且非常吸引人。和我小儿子坐在那里一边吃午饭，一边看着这些小雏鸟吃午饭，这种感觉真的非常好。所以，是的，我想——而且我想你们也在咖啡馆的窗外设置了鸟类喂食器。所以，即使你感觉信心不足，或者行动不便不适合到处走动，你也可以通过去这些中心来与自然互动，看到你在自己家里或阳台上看不到的东西，
by going to these centres that might just really kind of lift your soul so I really liked that about the centre actually. Yeah it's a inviting space um and we're trying to make it as inclusive as possible um within our means um and uh yeah like you said the cafe is a great space for people that may not be as mobile but we do have some mobility scooters but not loads so you know some people will have to sometimes wait um so that we can get um that level of access onto the nature reserve at brandon marsh which is our headquarters um but yes if you just want a cup of tea and to look out of the window we always have the bird feeders full and yeah it attracts so much wildlife not just the birds actually we've had monk jack deer fox foxes. Yeah, a real mix of wildlife.
这真的能净化你的心灵。我真的很喜欢中心的这一点。是的，这是一个温馨的空间，在我们的能力范围内，我们尽量让它具有包容性。而且，正如你所说，对于行动可能不太方便的人来说，咖啡馆是一个很棒的空间。我们确实有一些代步车，但数量不多，所以有时候有些人可能需要等一等，以便我们能在布兰登沼泽（Brandon Marsh）——也就是我们的总部——提供那种无障碍通道进入自然保护区。不过，是的，如果你只是想喝杯茶，向窗外望去，我们的鸟类喂食器总是满满的。是的，它吸引了如此多的野生动物，不仅仅是鸟类，实际上我们还见过赤麂（muntjac deer）和狐狸。是的，野生动物种类非常丰富。
I love that. My little boy told me that I had to ask you, he's six and a half, I had to ask you about certain wildlife, whether you have it or you don't have it. And I was like, I think some of these he definitely won't have. A flamingo. Okay, so that's a definite no, but it would be great. Okay, yes. He asked about foxes and you've said yes to foxes yeah badgers yes um most likely we do um i'm not aware of any badger sets so that's
我太喜欢了。我小儿子告诉我，他让我问你——他今年六岁半——让我问你有没有某些野生动物。我说，有些动物你们肯定没有。火烈鸟。好吧，那肯定没有，不过那倒挺酷的。好吧，是的。他问了狐狸，你刚才说有狐狸。是的。獾呢？是的，很有可能我们有。我不知道有没有任何獾洞——
the um network of underground tunnels where they live and i'm not aware of any that are active but i wouldn't be surprised if badgers use our nature reserve, even if they don't live there, if that makes sense. OK. And I know moles are not always people's friends, especially like farmers. Do you have moles and do you like them if you do? Well, I love all wildlife. And I know that's a biased thing to say. I know people aren't like a fan of certain things because, you know, creepy crawlies and all know that's a biased thing to say um i know people aren't like a fan of certain things because um you know creepy callies and all of that but i like to try and break that stigma because if um you know um if we can change i suppose the narrative on certain um wildlife being
也就是它们生活的地下隧道网络。我不知道有没有活跃的獾洞，但如果獾使用我们的自然保护区，即使它们不住在那里，我也不会感到惊讶，这样说能理解吗？好的。我知道鼹鼠并不总是人们的朋友，尤其是对农民而言。你们有鼹鼠吗？如果有的话，你们喜欢它们吗？嗯，我喜欢所有的野生动物。我知道带着偏见说这话不太好。我知道人们可能不喜欢某些东西，因为，你知道的，爬虫之类的所有这些东西。我知道带着偏见说这话不太好。我知道人们可能不喜欢某些东西，因为，你知道的，爬虫之类的所有这些东西。但我喜欢尝试打破这种刻板印象，因为如果，你知道的，如果我们可以改变对某些野生动物的看法，不再认为它们
scary or maybe a bit gross um i think that can especially with the younger generation um i think that will be a good way to i suppose break down that barrier of nature not always being for me i suppose as well but um in answer to your question about the moles i like moles um they have a part of um what will, what I mean is that they're a part of our ecosystem. They have their place. In terms of them being on a nature reserve, I think they would be. But I don't see any molehills on our reserves that often. So, again, I don't know if they use it that much.
吓人或者有点恶心，我认为这尤其对年轻一代来说——我认为这是打破“大自然不总是属于我”这种障碍的好方法。不过，关于你对鼹鼠的问题的回答，我喜欢鼹鼠。它们是我们生态系统的一部分，有它们的一席之地。至于它们是否在自然保护区里，我想是有的。不过我在我们的保护区里并不经常看到鼹鼠丘。所以，同样地，我不知道它们使用这里的频率有多高。
But, I mean, they use them in my garden a lot because there's loads of molecules. Thank you. Thank you for entertaining my six-and-a-half-year-old. He'll be delighted to know those answers. You're welcome. And, yeah, as you were talking, I was thinking, well, when I grew up, I was outside so much. I constantly had my hands in the dirt or was playing with insects.
不过，我的意思是，它们经常在我的花园里出没，因为那里有很多鼹鼠丘。谢谢。谢谢你陪我六岁半的孩子玩这个游戏。他听到这些答案一定会很高兴的。不客气。而且，是的，正如你刚才所说，我在想，当我小的时候，我大部分时间都在户外。我的手上总是沾满泥土，或者在玩昆虫。
I don't know if you're supposed to play with them. You know, putting them in jars and having a look at them and then putting them back, of course. And like, you know, slugs. I still don't like slugs very much. They are quite ugly creatures. But, you know, moving snails and looking at caterpillars and, you know, butterflies.
我不知道你是不是应该玩它们。你知道的，把它们放进罐子里观察一下，然后当然再把它们放回大自然。还有，像鼻涕虫（slugs）。我还是不太喜欢鼻涕虫。它们确实是挺丑的生物。但是，你知道的，移动蜗牛、观察毛毛虫还有蝴蝶。
And I just, I don't think how young people are getting out as often as that and certainly not getting their hands muddy. They're more disgusted by that, I think in my experience certainly of parenting how's that playing out for you as you try and educate young people about the benefits of being outside well particularly with the younger generation and like you were saying I think I can definitely see and at the trust we can see that there is this I suppose culture if you like and mindset about being outdoors in the mud is like a bad thing.
而且，我认为现在的年轻人不像以前那样经常去户外了，更不用说把手弄得泥泞不堪了。根据我作为父母的经验，他们对那种情况似乎感到更反感。你在试图教育年轻人了解户外活动的好处时，情况是怎样的呢？嗯，特别是在年轻一代中，正如你所说，我绝对能看到，而且我们在信托基金也能看到，存在着这样一种文化和心态，即认为去户外的泥地里是一件坏事。
And our education team are fantastic at, I suppose, breaking that stigma a little bit and that mindset by working with schools and families to really get stuck in. We have a mud kitchen at Brandon Marsh like a little education area and also we have a den building woods which is a great way for the younger generation in particular but I'm very happy to do it myself is things like den building so that's a great way of nature play isn't it just going outdoors and being creative out in nature which I think is a really important thing. Sounds like you've got an absolutely great job Dan. I was just saying that I do love my job yes I've done elements of all
我们的教育团队非常擅长打破这种刻板印象和心态，他们通过与学校和家庭合作，让孩子们真正全身心投入。我们在布兰登沼泽有一个泥巴厨房（mud kitchen），就像一个小型教育区，我们还有一个搭建窝棚的树林。对于年轻一代（当然我自己也很乐意去做）来说，像搭建窝棚这样的大自然游戏是极好的方式，只要去户外，在大自然中发挥创造力，我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。听起来你有一份非常棒的工作，丹。我刚才就说过，我确实很热爱我的工作。是的，我做过我向你提到的所有
the things that I've mentioned to you you. I have done some work with families before. I've delivered some of the wellbeing projects as well and doing the courses and the volunteering. Yeah, so my role and my conservation career so far has been very diverse, which I really love. Brilliant. It shines out of you. It's's lovely to see and I know before you were an action for nature officer you were doing the kind of health and well-being role so there might potentially be scope for people that are interested in nature to still do things that is you know kind of clinically relevant as well potentially you're still using outcome measures for some of your
事情的各个部分。我以前做过与家庭相关的工作，我也交付过一些福祉项目，还负责过课程和志愿服务。所以，到目前为止，我的角色和我的自然保护职业生涯非常多元化，我真的很喜欢这一点。太棒了！这种热情从你身上散发出来，看到这一幕真好。我知道在成为自然行动官员（action for nature officer）之前，你从事的是健康与福祉方面的角色，所以对于对自然感兴趣的人来说，可能仍然有空间去从事（你知道的）具有临床相关性的工作。你可能仍在为某些干预措施使用结果指标，
interventions you're kind of rubbing up alongside people who are doing you know perhaps PhDs or research and it's a good chance to work with you know a wide variety of people. Yeah definitely so we welcome people that are in research posts to approach us with their project idea for gaining their research and also to shadow us as well to get a greater perspective of what we do as an organisation. We've worked with a variety of different PhD students in the past. So, you know, we do welcome that interest. We might not be always able to facilitate and support them, but it's worth reaching out just in case. So in terms of the current work that we're offering in the health and wellbeing team, so we're still running those five ways to wellbeing courses
你会与那些可能在攻读博士学位或从事研究的人共事，这是一个与形形色色的人合作的好机会。是的，绝对是的。所以我们欢迎从事研究岗位的人带着他们的项目构想来找我们，以获取他们的研究成果，同时也欢迎他们跟岗实习，从而对我们作为一个组织所做的工作有更深入的视角。我们过去曾与各种不同的博士生合作过。所以，我们欢迎这种兴趣。虽然我们可能并不总是能够促成和支持他们，但以防万一，还是值得联系我们的。至于我们健康与福祉团队目前提供的服务，我们仍在各个县的不同地区开设这些“福祉五种方式”课程。
at different areas in the county. And we are running volunteering opportunities and wellbeing walks as well through our project called The Environment and Me, which is shortened to TEAM, which I think is really nice. Really sort of, yes, it's a great project that's started in Coventry and now they've expanded across Warwickshire as well, where they're delivering a variety of different opportunities in different areas for people that are experiencing mental ill health. But you don't have to be diagnosed with depression or anxiety, for example, to access those opportunities. Some people do feel like, oh, they need to have that label, if you like, or diagnosis when that isn't the case. We welcome and are open to a variety of different people from all sorts of backgrounds coming to those opportunities
我们还在通过一个名为“环境与我”（The Environment and Me，简称 TEAM）的项目开展志愿服务机会和福祉步行活动。我觉得这个名字真好。这确实是一个在考文垂发起并现已扩展到整个沃里克郡的伟大项目，他们在不同地区为正在经历心理健康困扰的人们提供各种不同的机会。但你不需要被诊断出患有抑郁症或焦虑症才能获得这些机会。有些人确实觉得，哦，如果不是那样的话，他们就需要有那样的标签或诊断。我们欢迎并对来自各种背景的形形色色的人开放，让他们参与到这些机会中来，
where some opportunities may be more suitable than others um and if you just typed in on google warwickshire wildlife trust um health and well-being there will be the current opportunities that we have um that may be relevant and that you can come to. Brilliant. So would volunteering roles be up there as well, or is that a case of contacting your local wildlife trust to explore what might be an option? So with the volunteering at Warwickshire Wildlife Trust, again, you can easily find that on our website. So if you just type in Watch Royal Trust Volunteering onto Google, there'll be a page which outlines the process you need to go through to be enrolled as a volunteer and then maybe have a taster session
其中有些机会可能比其他机会更合适。如果你在谷歌上搜索“沃里克郡野生动物信托基金 健康与福祉”，就能找到我们目前提供的可能相关的机会，你可以参与其中。太棒了。那么志愿者的岗位也会在那里列出吗，还是需要联系你当地的野生动物信托基金去探索可能有的选择？关于沃里克郡野生动物信托基金的志愿者工作，同样，你可以很容易地在我们的网站上找到。如果你在谷歌上搜索“沃里克野生信托志愿者”（Watch Royal Trust Volunteering），就会有一个页面概述了你需要经历的流程，以便被注册为志愿者，然后可能会与负责该区域的相关保护区官员进行一次体验式会面。
with the relevant reserves officer that is covering that area. So we have a North, South south east and west reserves officer so it just depends on maybe the geography of where that person is so if they're Leamington based and they want to really be around that area then our Vontage coordinator Wendy can align your interests and availability with the right opportunities basically so it just makes it an easy process um brilliant and one thing i wanted to touch on because i know you did mention it before um but i haven't mentioned it yet is the sort of interventions and the measuring of um the work that we do so with some of our projects within the health and well-being team
我们有负责北部、南部、东部和西部的保护区官员，这取决于该人的地理位置。所以如果他们住在利明顿，并且真的很想在那个区域活动，那么我们的志愿者协调员温迪（Wendy）就可以根据你的兴趣和时间安排，将你与合适的机会进行匹配，这让整个流程变得非常简单。太棒了！我想提及的一件事是——因为我知道你之前提到过，但我还没提到过——那就是我们工作的干预措施和效果评估。特别是对于我们健康与福祉团队的一些项目，
in particular we do track people's state of well-being and mood through the Warwick Edinburgh mental well-being scale so that's a great way to measure the impact that our opportunities have on people's lives so I think a really important aspect is the anecdotal evidence so the stories that you capture just out on the reserve when you're walking with that person just saying how this has been a lifeline for them because I was running those opportunities that I referenced before in Covid so it was a tricky time for people with social isolation and loneliness and those opportunities were a great gateway for them to access nature and support their mental health and meet new people
我们确实通过“华威爱丁堡心理福祉量表”（Warwick Edinburgh Mental Well-being Scale）来追踪人们的福祉状态和情绪，这是衡量我们的机会对人们生活产生的影响的好方法。我认为一个非常重要的方面是轶事证据，也就是你在保护区里散步时，与那个人并肩行走时收集到的故事，他们说这如何成为了他们的生命线。因为我在新冠疫情期间负责我前面提到的那些机会，所以对人们来说，由于社交隔离和孤独，那是一段棘手的时期。这些机会是他们接触自然、支持心理健康以及结识新朋友的绝佳途径。
as well and I know some people that have actually started leading walks with the people that were on the same course on the same nature reserve i was running those sessions so i think that's just such a positive outcome to our offer um but yes um alongside that i was tracking people's um state of well-being from the start and then there was a midpoint question there that we we put in and it gave to the people and then there was an end one so and we would be able to track things like their mood and general sort of thoughts and feelings as well. That's great it's always good to have evidence the importance to organisations and government bodies like the NHS, for example, where we're trying and we are working with them on a local level to create this green prescribing approach. And there is a big thing around social prescribing, which really does have its place and it's so important. And we are integrated within that system where we've built up contacts with certain social
我也认识一些人，他们实际上开始带领那些和我一起在同一个自然保护区上同一门课程的人进行散步。所以我认为这真的是我们提供的服务的一个非常积极的结果。但除此之外，我还会从一开始就追踪人们的福祉状态，中间我们会给人们问一个中期问题，然后还有一个期末问题。因此，我们能够追踪诸如他们的情绪以及一般性的思考和感觉之类的事情。这太棒了。拥有证据总是好的，这对于组织和政府机构（例如 NHS，我们正在努力并在地方层面上与他们合作以创建这种绿色处方方法）非常重要。围绕社会处方有一个很大的趋势，它确实有其一席之地，而且非常重要。我们已经融入了这个系统，与附加在全科医生身上的某些社会处方师建立了联系。因此，他们会在适当时将部分客户转介给我们的服务。但是，我们也觉得确实有必要拥有绿色处方方法，因为我们深知走到户外大自然中是多么重要，它对人们的心理健康有多么重要。所以，是的，这是一个缓慢的过程，但我们非常热切希望它能成为融入医疗系统的一部分。是的，太棒了。你刚才提到了封锁期。我知道对某些人来说，那是他们真正开始更多地投入园艺，或者观察窗外发生的事情的时期。自从封锁以来，你有没有看到更多的人对大自然产生兴趣，或者人们对外部世界的兴趣有所增加？是的，绝对有。所以，我想特别是自我负责福祉课程和志愿服务时，人们表现出了极大的兴趣。因为我认为新冠疫情出于各种原因让人们慢了下来，并重新评估了他们的生活方式以及他们过生活的方式。
prescribers that are attached to GPs. So they will refer some of their clients where appropriate to our services. But also, we do feel like there's a need to actually have the green prescribing approach because we just know how so important the um being outdoors in nature isn't is like um you know it's for people's mental health um so uh yeah that's a slow process but we're really keen on it being something that's integrated within the health system. Yeah, brilliant. And you touched on lockdowns there. And I know for some people, that's a time where they really started to get more into their gardening or, you know, observing what was going on outside the window. Have you seen many, you know, more of an uptake since lockdown or people being
这些处方开具人员隶属于全科医生（GP）。因此，在合适的时候，他们会将部分客户转介到我们的服务机构。但同时，我们确实觉得有必要采用绿色处方的方法，因为我们深知身处户外和大自然对于人们心理健康的重要性……所以，是的，这是一个缓慢的过程，但我们非常希望它能成为融入医疗系统的一部分。是的，太棒了。你刚才提到了封城。据我所知，对某些人来说，那段时间他们真正开始更多地投入到园艺中，或者，你知道的，观察窗外发生的事情。自从封城以来，你发现参与度有所增加吗，或者人们是否
more interested in the outside world yeah definitely so um i think particularly when i was running the well-being courses and the volunteering there was a lot of interest because i think covid allowed people for a variety of reasons to slow down and maybe reassess their their lifestyle and how they led their lives so I think a lot of people have engaged with nature more positively and have maintained that as well um whereas i know some people probably wouldn't have done so it was maybe they'll put in that situation well you know you can't do anything else apart from go for a walk for an hour outside your house um which i still think was obviously really important for them at the time but
因此，我认为很多人更积极地与自然互动并保持了这种状态。而我也知道有些人可能没有这样做，他们可能处于那样一种情况：好吧，除了在房子外面走一个小时，你什么也做不了。虽然我仍然认为这在当时对他们来说显然非常重要，但
life takes over and maybe they weren't able to maintain that once things relax a little bit more but I do know a lot of people and also you know that's sort of through my work where I've been able to have these discussions where they've spoken about how it's just changed their lives and for the you know for the foreseeable and for the better yeah and do you think um Spring Watch and Autumn Watch shows with Chris Packham and Michaela Strachan, does that help people understand more? And are you getting people coming in saying,
生活接管了一切，一旦情况稍微放松，他们可能就无法维持那种状态了。但我认识很多人，也通过我的工作，能够进行这些讨论，他们谈到了这如何改变了他们的生活，为了可预见的未来和更好的未来。是的，你认为由克里斯·帕克姆（Chris Packham）和米凯拉·斯特拉汉（Michaela Strachan）主持的“春日观察”和“秋日观察”节目，是否能帮助人们了解更多？你是否发现有人跑来对你说：“哦，我在电视上看到了这个，你知道的，我真的很想近距离或者在我附近看到它？”是的，绝对是这样。我认为这些纪录片和节目在主流电视上占有一席之地。我真的希望它们不要被砍掉，因为我最近听说“春日观察”要被拿掉了，这真的很令人沮丧。我们还有一个“春日观察”，然后他们可能就不会再推出了，这真是一个巨大的遗憾。哦，不，这太遗憾了，我还没听说过呢。这真是一个遗憾，因为这类节目，是的，像——我想是山姆——我想这主要是BBC的一个预算决定，但我并不了解全部的内幕，我不想在这里引发争议。但基本上，这些节目为人们提供了如此多的灵感。
oh, I saw this on there, you know, I really wanted to see it like up close or close to me? Yeah, definitely. I think those documentaries and those shows, they have a real place on mainstream TV. And I really hope they don't go, because I heard recently about Springwatch being taken down, which is really upsetting. We've got one more Springwatch and then they may not bring it back, which is a real shame. Oh no, that is a shame, I hadn't heard that. which was a real shame because those sort of shows yeah like um i think it is sam i think it was
哦，我在那上面看到了这个，你知道的，我真的很想近距离或者在自己身边看到它？是的，绝对是。我认为这些纪录片和节目在主流电视上占有一席之地。我真心希望它们不要消失，因为我最近听说《Springwatch》要被停播了，这真的让人很难过。我们还有一个季度的《Springwatch》，之后他们可能就不会再续播了，这真的是个遗憾。噢，不，这太遗憾了，我还没听说过这事。这真的是个遗憾，因为这类节目，是的，就像……呃，我觉得是萨姆，我觉得是
mainly a budget decision um from the bbc but i don't know the whole ins and outs i don't want to be controversial on here um but essentially um those shows are they provide so much inspiration for people and um i think with um spring watch autumn watch and winter watch they're really good at um changing that narrative particularly at the end for people to take action as well for nature because um you know i'm sure a lot of us know that there is an environmental crisis and an ecological crisis. And what we want to do with how we work with communities as an organisation is encouraging people to take action for wildlife on a local level. level, so whether that be doing some more wildlife friendly gardening or changing the way you commute to work or a variety of different things that are fitting and tailored to their lives and suitable for them. So those shows are a great way in a line with how we want to engage with communities, which is taking action as well.
我认为通过“春日观察”、“秋日观察”和“冬日观察”，它们非常擅长改变这种叙事，特别是在最后敦促人们为自然采取行动。因为，你知道的，我相信我们中的许多人都知道存在着环境危机和生态危机。作为一个组织，我们希望在与社区的合作中做的是，鼓励人们在地方层面上为野生动物采取行动。所以，无论是进行更多对野生动物友好的园艺，还是改变你通勤上班的方式，或者是适合并贴合他们生活、适合他们的各种不同事情。因此，这些节目与我们希望与社区互动的方式完美契合，也就是同时采取行动。
So it's providing that inspiration, but then also leading to a call to action as well. It's also really useful to think about how the message about what you do and what you know populates out to you know to wider organizations as well so i know especially in coventry which is where i'm from some of the roundabouts in coventry have been put down to wildflower planting rather than constantly mowing them it's probably saves the probably saves the money that's probably what their main um main goal is but it's so lovely to see and it must be better for the wildlife surely oh it is yeah so I think they started doing that when the city of culture came to Coventry and so the council may have had some funding to start that process um but i think it it's um something that should be changed um for um the sort of the should be integrated into their management for the long term
所以它不仅提供灵感，还带来了行动的号召。思考关于你所做的事情和你的知识的信息如何向更广泛的组织普及，这也非常有用。我知道，特别是在考文垂（也就是我的家乡），考文垂的一些环岛已经改成了种植野花，而不是不断地割草。这可能为他们省了钱，这可能才是他们主要的、主要的目标，但看到这一幕真是太美好了，而且对野生动物肯定更好！哦，是的！所以我想他们是在考文垂成为文化之城（city of culture）时开始这样做的，所以市议会可能有一些资金来启动这个过程。但我觉得这应该是应该改变的事情，应该长期纳入他们的管理中，
and because it's so inviting to have that burst of color when you um arrive into coventry it's great for pollinators and like you said on a financial perspective they don't have to know it as much so I think it's a win-win situation really. Absolutely and how are the bees? Have you got bees on Brandon? Yeah, so we have a lot of wildflowers on our nature reserve, all nature reserves, like all of our reserves do have, you know, a variety of different wildflowers which support pollinators, not just bees, moths, butterflies, wasps, amongst others. So, yeah, we definitely try to manage our reserves to be as sympathetic as possible to a diversity of wildlife,
因为当你来到考文垂时，看到那片绚丽的色彩是如此引人入胜，这对传粉昆虫非常有利。而且正如你所说，从财务角度来看，他们不需要割那么多草了，所以我认为这是一个双赢的局面。绝对是这样。蜜蜂现在怎么样？你们布兰登有蜜蜂吗？是的，我们在自然保护区有很多野花。所有的自然保护区，就像我们所有的保护区一样，确实都有各种各样的野花来支持传粉昆虫，不仅是蜜蜂、飞蛾、蝴蝶、黄蜂，还有其他昆虫。所以，是的，我们绝对努力以尽可能对多种野生动物友好的方式来管理我们的保护区，
not just for a specific species. species um we feel on the whole because there is such a nature decline on you know across the board really that our approach should be to then manage our reserves in a way which is best for as much wildlife as possible yeah thank you absolutely agree how did you get into wildlife and you know start to think about making it your career Dan? So it sounds a bit cliche but I um you know from a young age I've always loved nature and being outdoors and my dad bought my first pair of binoculars because I'm really into bird watching and you know I remember going out to a country park and making bird boxes and bat boxes and taking them back home and I think that just sort of sparked an interest from a very young age throughout my life until
而不仅仅是为了某个特定的物种。我们觉得总体上，由于普遍存在自然衰退的现象，我们的方法应该是以最适合尽可能多的野生动物的方式来管理我们的保护区。是的，完全同意。丹，你是怎么进入野生动物领域的，并且开始考虑把它作为你的职业的？这听起来可能有点老套，但我从小就一直热爱大自然和户外活动。我爸爸给我买了我人生中第一副双千里镜，因为我对观鸟非常感兴趣。我记得我曾去过一个郊野公园，制作鸟箱和蝙蝠箱并把它们带回家。我想这从很小的时候就点燃了我的兴趣，一直贯穿我的人生，直到
where I am now and whereas sometimes there's always a bit of a gap and it sort of falls, you know, once you're in your teens and then you may get it back. But for me, I've always sort of been interested in nature and the outdoors. So I studied a conservation degree at Bangor University and loved it there. I don't know if you've been to that area of North Wales but it's just the perfect spot for doing a conservation degree
我现在的状态。虽然有时候总会有一些间隙，当你在十几岁时可能会放下它，然后你可能会重新拾起它。但对我来说，我对大自然和户外活动一直保持着兴趣。因此我在班戈大学（Bangor University）攻读了自然保护学位，并且非常喜欢那里的生活。我不知道你去没去过北威尔士的那个地区，那简直是攻读自然保护学位的绝佳地点。
and then yeah from that point I did some sort of short-term seasonal contracts as like a graduate level in a very unusual role. So I was actually protecting rare seabirds on beaches in North Wales, Suffolk and Norfolk. Random, but a really important job because they were threatened for a variety of different reasons. And then I broadened out my sort of way of working in the conservation sector. So one part of the role that I really enjoyed when I was doing the seabird stuff was engaging with the public. So I thought community engagement role would be really fitting for me so then I went to Warwickshire Wildlife Trust and got maternity cover and they haven't been able to get rid of me since you're not going anywhere I love that if you could offer our listeners kind of three top tips, either for themselves or for the clients they're supporting,
然后，是的，从那时起，我做了一些短期季节性合同的工作，比如在毕业生阶段从事一份非常寻常的工作。我实际上是在北威尔士、萨福克郡（Suffolk）和诺福克郡（Norfolk）的海滩上保护珍稀海鸟。这很随机，但这是一项非常重要的工作，因为它们由于各种不同的原因受到威胁。然后我拓宽了我在自然保护领域的的工作方式。在我做海鸟相关工作时，我真正喜欢的一个角色部分是与公众互动。所以我认为社区参与的角色非常适合我，于是我去了沃里克郡野生动物信托基金（Warwickshire Wildlife Trust）做产假替补，他们就再也甩不掉我了。你哪儿都不会去，我太喜欢这样了。如果你能为我们的听众提供三个首要建议，无论是为了他们自己还是为了他们所支持的客户，
about ways to include wildlife more in their day-to-day lives, what might they be? Oh, good question. Put you on the spot. Yeah, you have, but I'll try my best to answer. So I think one thing would be to go for a walk somewhere and consciously make an effort to appreciate your surroundings so have like a mindful walk and I think a lot of us just go from A to B and you know with our busy lives and you know we're all thinking
关于如何在日常生活中更多地融入野生动物，那会是什么呢？哦，好问题。把我难住了。是的，你确实问了个难题，但我会尽力回答。我想其中一件事就是去某个地方散步，并有意识地努力去欣赏周围的环境，进行一次正念漫步。我认为我们很多人在忙碌的生活中只是从A点走到B点，你知道的，我们都在想，
you know I need to put this on my shopping list or I need to do this later when actually we slow down and just connect with nature on a deeper level I think that would be a really good way with practice you know it's not just something you can do at click of a finger because I think we we do have busy minds and it's not an easy process sometimes for people but with practice I think you can do a mindful walk and it'd be a part of your daily life and it doesn't have to be So I would say that was my first one. Another one would be to learn something new about wildlife that you an app on your phone to find out more about the bird song that you're listening to and you don't know what it is. So discovering a little bit more about what's around you as well. And then you can share that with a family member or a friend.
“我需要把这个加到我的购物清单上，或者我稍后需要做这个”。而实际上，当我们慢下来，在更深层次上与自然连接时，我认为这将是一个非常好的方法。通过练习——这并不是说你打个响指就能做到的，因为我认为我们确实思绪纷繁，对人们来说这有时并不是一个简单的过程——但通过练习，我认为你可以进行一次正念漫步，并让它成为你日常生活的一部分。这并不难。所以我会说这是我的第一个建议。另一个建议是了解一些关于野生动物的新知识，比如你在手机上下载一个应用程序，来了解你正在听到的但又不知道是什么的鸟鸣声。因此，多了解一些你周边的环境。然后你可以与家人或朋友分享这些知识。
And you're passing on that knowledge, which I think is a really positive thing as well and can lift people's mood. And then another one, I think, would be to maybe go on to our website of warwickshire wildlife trust um i'm not going to try and plug too much but um we have um a a new way of working with communities and like i sort of mentioned earlier um which is team wilder and we're wanting more people to take action for wildlife like I was mentioning so if you go onto that part of our website so Team Wilder Watch Wildlife Trust just type that into Google
你在传递这些知识，我认为这也是一件非常积极的事情，可以提升人们的情绪。然后还有另一个建议，我想，也许可以访问我们沃里克郡野生动物信托基金的网站——我不想过多地卖力宣传，但是——我们有一种与社区合作的新方法，就像我刚才提到的那样，那就是“狂野团队”（Team Wilder）。我们希望更多的人像我刚才提到的一样为野生动物采取行动。所以，如果你访问我们网站的那一部分——在谷歌上搜索“狂野团队 沃里克野生信托基金”（Team Wilder Watch Wildlife Trust）——
and you'll find out more about what we're doing as an organisation and we have a map which people have been from the public have been plotting their actions for wildlife so you can maybe get some inspiration about what people are doing and maybe nearby where you live so it'd be interesting to see if you live in Coventry for example there may be some people that have plotted something in from what they've done in their gardens um so some positive actions that may inspire you to also do the same or if you're already doing something that'd be fantastic to hear from you about what you're doing and then
你就会更多地了解我们作为一个组织在做的事情。我们有一张地图，公众一直在上面绘制他们为野生动物采取的行动，所以你可以从人们正在做的事情中获得一些灵感，也许就在你居住的附近。看看如果你住在考文垂，可能会发现有些人绘制了他们在花园里做过的事情，所以这些积极的行动可能会激励你也这样做；或者如果你已经在做一些事情，听到你正在做的事情会是非常棒的。然后
you can contribute and then we can capture that and um you know those actions and those stories stories um which is a yeah a great um way for us to know what people are doing and for nature it really is thank you for your tips i know i put you on the spot there but you did very well people are listening probably um nationally and sometimes even internationally um we've so far i realized yesterday covered some like 38 of the world have listened to an episode of the podcast, which is pretty incredible. Is Team Wilder just a localised approach or does it go more broadly outside in the UK? Do you know? So it goes across the UK, actually. So I don't know if the listeners are aware of the wildlife trusts and how they work but it's actually a network of individual wildlife trusts so there's a Warwickshire wildlife
你可以贡献一份力量，我们可以收集这些行动和故事。这对于我们了解人们在做什么以及为了大自然而言，确实是一个极好的方式。非常感谢你的建议。我知道我刚才把你问住了，但你做得非常好。听众们可能分布在全国各地，有时甚至在国际上——我昨天意识到，到目前为止，我们播客的听众已经覆盖了全球大约 38% 的地区，这相当惊人。“狂野团队”仅仅是一个本土化的方法，还是它在英国更广泛地推行？你知道吗？实际上它在整个英国都在推行。所以，我不知道听众们是否了解野生动物信托基金以及它们是如何运作的，但它实际上是一个独立野生动物信托基金的网络，所以有一个沃里克郡野生动物信托基金
trust there's an Essex wildlife trust Norfolk wildlife trust etc etc so primarily county-based and we work together as a movement as well so we are separate entities and we do have our own aims and aspirations but they are very similar to other wildlife trusts but we as a collective we have a lot more power to create the changes that we want to for nature and people. So the Team Wilder approach is a part of that collective. So if there was someone that was listening in Essex, for example, there are teams in that organisation that are at the moment um you know taking this approach to um team wilder and having more people take action for wildlife um yeah so in answer to your question um yes so um people can find out more in their local area as well brilliant thank you thank you so much for your passion for wildlife and helping us learn a bit more about why it's useful and how it can be really part of somebody's day to day life,'re really wanting more people to be inspired and connect to nature.
相信有埃 Essex 野生动物信托基金、诺福克野生动物信托基金等等，所以它们主要是以县为单位的，我们作为一个运动也在合作，所以我们是独立的实体，我们有自己的目标和愿景，但它们与其他的野生动物信托基金非常相似，但作为一个集体，我们拥有更多的力量来为自然和人们创造我们想要的改变。因此，“Wilder 团队”的方法就是那个集体的一部分。因此，举例来说，如果在埃塞克斯郡有人在收听，该组织中现在有团队，你知道的，正在采用这种方法来建立“wilder 团队”，让更多的人为野生动物采取行动，是的，所以回答你的问题，是的，人们也可以在他们的当地了解更多信息，太棒了，谢谢你，非常感谢你对野生动物的热情，并帮助我们更多地了解为什么它很有用，以及它如何真正成为某人日常生活的一部分，我们真的希望更多的人受到启发并与大自然建立联系。
And as I keep saying, let's take action. But I think it's just so important that we're doing our own bit for the environment because those small actions can amount to a large and positive and significant impact great i will obviously make sure i put all of your um wildlife trust website address details in the show notes so people can absolutely access that speedily if they want to but thank you so much for your time today dan you're welcome thank you very much thank you so much to our guest dan lovard um really lovely speaking with him and really thoughtful guy that's got um you know really nice outlook on the world so i hope you found that really useful and that you will find it useful for thinking about how you can interact with nature and wildlife and how you
正如我一直所说的那样，让我们采取行动。但我认为，我们为环境尽自己的一份力是如此重要，因为这些小小的行动可以积聚成巨大、积极和重大的影响。太好了，我显然会确保把你们所有的野生动物信托基金网站地址详情都放在节目简介中，这样人们如果想的话绝对可以快速访问，非常感谢你今天抽出时间，丹，不用谢，非常感谢。非常感谢我们的嘉宾丹·洛瓦德，与他交谈真的非常愉快，他是一个非常有思想的人，你知道的，他对世界有着非常好的看法，所以我希望你觉得这真的很有用，你会发现它有助于思考你如何与大自然和野生动物互动，以及你
can also help showcase and highlight the benefits of that to your clients too. I'd love any feedback you might have on this episode or any others. Do come and join us in the Aspiring Psychologist Community free Facebook group. If I don't see you there, I will be along in your ears from 6am on Monday for our next podcast episode. Thank you. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective With this podcast that you're sad You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
也可以帮助向你的客户展示和强调这一点的好处。我非常欢迎你对本期节目或任何其他节目的反馈。快来加入我们的“有抱负的心理学家社区”免费 Facebook 群组吧。如果我在那里没见到你，我将从周一早上 6 点开始在你的耳边陪伴你的下一个播客节目。谢谢。有抱负的心理学家集体 有了这个播客，你会很难过 你会走上获得资格的道路 这是有抱负的心理学家播客 与玛丽安·特伦特博士一起 我叫亚娜，我是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现它非常有趣，关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家，通往那里的途径之多让我感到惊叹，而且没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力，所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但是相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。